[Musique]
c'est à l'unanimité que les élus de
l'assemblée départementale adopte le
budget primitif 2022 la collectivité un
budget de 1 milliards 218 millions
d'euros en progression de plus de 6% un
budget qui se veut volontariste parce
que les temps sont durs pour les
familles réunionnaises entre le chômage
la précarité la pauvreté les problèmes
d'éducation pour les marmailles les
problèmes de logement et bien le
département doit essayer en tout cas
d'apporter les meilleures solutions les
meilleures réponses à tous ces problèmes
c'est tous les enjeux que nous portons
département un budget qui portent tous
les domaines d'intervention de la
collectivité comme l'insertion la
culture l'enfance la famille la jeunesse
l'agriculture et l'eau une grande partie
de ce budget est consacré à l'action
sociale on va multiplier par deux le
nombre d'améliorations de logements on
va porter l'un ciation des jeunes en
difficulté on va porter les aides aux
familles à la parentalité à la petite
enfance lutter contre les violences
intrafamiliales
donc ce sera le voir à tous les enjeux
qu'il y a dans son projet de budget est
bien évidemment nous pensons aussi au
monde agricole les élus se sont
également engagés auprès des familles
touchées sinistrés après l'incendié de
leur immeuble sur saint-denis
accompagner on l'a fait avec les
travailleurs sociaux nos médecins de pmi
et nous avons ce matin voté un rapport
de qui donne une enveloppe financière à
la ville de saint denis à 116 pour aller
encore plus loin dans l'accompagnement
des familles c'est une enveloppe de 160
de 10000 euros qui a été votée attribue
le au ccs qui fait chaque jour des
efforts d'accompagnement le budget
primitif 2022 est une première phase de
l'action départementale inscrits dans le
plan de mandature 2021 2028
[Musique]